تذكر عندما لم تتوقف Spring Breakers في فلوريدا عن الحفلات حتى بعد أن ضرب جائحة فيروس كورونا الولايات المتحدة ، فما حدث عندما انتهت عطلة الربيع ، يمكننا في الواقع تتبع حركة هذه الأجهزة خلال الأسابيع المتبقية من شهر مارس لمعرفة أين ذهبت هذه الأجهزة بعد Spring Breakers تركت الشاطئ ، فما تشاهده في هذا الفيديو هو ما يحدث إذا لم يمارس الناس التباعد الاجتماعي حيث تجمع مجموعة من الأفراد الذين تعرفهم أو بضعة آلاف من الأشخاص في هذه الحالة على شاطئ في فورت لودرديل فلوريدا وجميع الأماكن العميقة السفر الذي يعرض مدى ترابط عالمنا هو وضع x-mode لجوش أنتون رون ، وهي شركة تتعقب حركة الأجهزة مثل الهواتف المحمولة ، ويقول فريقه إنها تستخدم بيانات الموقع لتتبع المكان الذي ذهب إليه كل شخص على الشاطئ في فورت لودرديل في مارس بعد مغادرته بما في ذلك تلك Spring Breakers من نيويورك إلى الغرب الأوسط حتى كندا ، فأنت تعلم قوة بيانات الموقع هذه ، ويمكن استخدامها لفهمك ليس فقط  تعرف على كيفية سفر الأشخاص وأين
يسافرون بعد التجمع ولكن من
المحتمل أيضًا أن تستعد وأن تكون
استباقيًا ، يحدث شيء ما بشكل صحيح
لتحديد النقاط الساخنة المستقبلية
للمكان الذي يمكن أن يحدث فيه فيروس crota
قبل حدوثه ولكن تطبيقات
تقنية أوضاع X تذهب إلى ما هو أبعد من ذلك
يقول أنطون إن الشركة
تتعقب خمسة وعشرين مليون جهاز
شهريًا في الولايات المتحدة وملايين
آخرين حول العالم ، وتقول الطالبات
إنها مستعدة للعمل مع
الحكومات والمجموعات الأخرى للمساعدة في
وقف انتشار فيروس كورونا الذي
نعمل معه  أنت تعرف التطبيقات التي
تستخدم موقعًا حقيقيًا لحالة الاستخدام لتشغيل
الموقع سواء كانت تطبيقات نقل
سواء كانت تطبيقات الطقس أو التطبيقات التي
تنبهك بشأن الزلازل التي
تحدث هناك ،
ثم نقوم بدمج تقنية الموقع لدينا
للسماح بمشاركة البيانات حيث
يمكن للمستخدم الاشتراك  لمشاركة بيانات الموقع الخاصة بهم ،
فإننا نلتزم بـ gdpr ، فنحن نلتزم بقانون
CCPA ولكننا نحاول تجاوز
ذلك  أنت تعلم أن ما نسميه الخصوصية
مدركًا لما تدعي الشركة
وترخصها أن البيانات لأطراف ثالثة
بما في ذلك المعلن
دون أي معلومات تعريف شخصية
يمكن استخدام
تقنيتك لتتبع الأفراد الذين سيتعقبونني ، فقد
يكون من الصواب أننا لا نسمح بذلك ولا نسمح بذلك
لن نسمح لأي من شركائنا بالقيام
بذلك لأننا لا نعتقد أن هذا هو
الشيء الصحيح للقيام بعمل
جيد ، يقول أنطون إن شركته تبذل قصارى
جهدها للحفاظ على أمان البيانات ولا
تحدد مالكي الأجهزة التي
تتعقبها هناك.
مخاوف الخصوصية بشأن هذا النوع من التكنولوجيا
في عام 2018 أظهر تحقيق أجرته صحيفة New York Times
كيف يمكن استخدام بيانات الموقع
لتحديد المالك المحدد
لجهاز معين تعرفه ، ولا أعتقد أن
الكثير من الأشخاص يدركون أنه حتى هذه
التكنولوجيا موجودة أنها خارج
هناك وأعتقد أن بعض الأشخاص قد
تسللوا إلى حد ما ، فماذا ستقول للأشخاص
الذين لديهم مخاوف عندما يرون
أنه يمكنك تتبع أجهزة مثل
هذه  ote العم بن من
الرجل العنكبوت الذي يتمتع بقوة
كبيرة يأتي بمسؤولية كبيرة تمامًا كما
تعلم أعتقد أن هناك خطًا رفيعًا وأعتقد
أنه من المهم جدًا أن يوافق المستخدمون
على ذلك ومن المهم جدًا أن
تعود عند غراء أستاذ البيانات هذا
رومر لتأتي إلى هنا
لأنني أعلم أنك قمت للتو بقياس
مقدار الضرر الذي
يحدث على الإنتاج على أساس شهري من الناحية المالية ومن الظرف الخلفي ومقارنة
ذلك ربما بتكلفة ضخ
الأموال في القطاع الطبي إلى
إنتاج عدد الاختبارات التي نطلبها سواء
أكان لدي فيروس كورونا الآن أم
لا ،
تحدثنا من خلال الرياضيات هنا ، من فضلك ،
تقديري الآن هو
أننا نفقد ما يقرب من ثلاث إلى أربعمائة
مليار دولار شهريًا من الناتج الذي
لا ننتجه ودخلًا
لا نحققه إذا أنفقنا مائة مليار
دولار في الأشهر الـ 12 التالية التي تعلمناها
لتحسين جودة اختباراتنا في
ابتكار توسيع نطاق  الاختبارات الإلكترونية التي أجريناها
بالفعل يمكننا التعافي بسرعة أكبر بكثير ،
وقد نتجنب
خسارة أربعمائة مليار دولار كل
شهر وهناك تكلفة أخرى لتأخير
الاسترداد وهي أننا قد لا نكون
قادرين على التعافي من بعض الأشياء التي
اعتدنا القيام بها  قبل أن يكون المستوى الذي نعود إليه
قد يكون أقل إذا تأخرنا لفترة طويلة جدًا ، لذا فإن
التعافي الأسرع سيكون ذا قيمة كبيرة
جدًا ، فكيف يتم سحب قناع 10 سنت
منا أو عدم
توفره بسهولة كان مفاجئًا حقًا
[موسيقى  ]
shapeways هي عبارة عن منصة تصنيع رقمية مدعومة من المشروع
ومتخصصة بشكل
خاص في الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد مع الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد ، حيث
يمكنك إنتاج
أجزاء تصنيع قصيرة المدى
تُستخدم عادةً مثل النقص الذي نعاني منه
في سلسلة التوريد اليوم ، وقد
قمنا بتحويل أعمالنا بالكامل
وسيلة لدعم هذه
الأزمة ينتشر الفيروس على قطرة ،
ما يحاول الفيروس القيام به هو محاولة
الذهاب إلى أنفك أو فمك
حيث يوجد الجنة وهذا هو المكان
يأتي درع الوجه
لكنهم ليسوا مثل نوع من علم الصواريخ
في المحصلة النهائية ، أي شيء
يمنع هذا السقوط سيكون
أقنعة جراحية دقيقة صعبة لأنها
تتطلب ملاءمة شديدة للغاية
حول الوجه الآن.  درع الوجه الذي
شهدناه كثيرًا من النجاح في الوقت الحالي ، هناك
أكثر من عشرة مستشفيات في نيويورك تعمل
حاليًا على بيع النماذج الأولية أو استخدام
واقيات الوجه مع دروع Shapeways للوجه
عادةً للاستخدام لمرة واحدة بين
أربعة وستة دولارات
نبيعها للمستشفيات  عند 40 دولارًا من درع الوجه
وهو نموذج قابل لإعادة الاستخدام ويمكن
تنظيفه وتطهيره ، نشعر أن
التطبيق متعدد الاستخدامات أفضل نظرًا
لوجود نقص في المواد
عبر المساحة التي أفكر فيها في درع الوجه
بالطريقة نفسها التي أفكر بها في سطح
مثلك تمامًا  قم بتنظيف سطح المنضدة الخاصة بك
في مطبخك ، فلن تضطر
إلى استبدال سطح كونترتوب المطبخ في كل
مرة يسعل فيها شخص ما ، يمكنك تنظيفه بسهولة
عندما تبدأ في رؤية نقص في
الإمدادات  السلاسل التي تعرف أنها
مناسبة تمامًا للطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
[موسيقى]